are you still kind of tapped out on
on a season two it's not even about
being tapped out it's more about
me feeling like
wanting to honor what watchmen was
before
i became a part of it and that the
legacy of watchmen is
alan and dave created it um
and uh and it sat for 30 years
obviously zac zack made his movie which
was a pretty canonical
um adaptation of of the of the
12 issues and then we made our
season of television and then and that
was my that was my turn
you know it's like i got in the middle
of the dance floor
for a minute and got to do my move but
then you retreat to the edge of the
circle
and it's someone else's turn to dance
and
uh this is a horrible metaphor because
i'm you don't want to see me dance under
any circumstances
suffice to say that i just feel like
what's best for watchmen
this thing that i love is for someone
else to take their
their shot at it and i think that that's
just going to be much more interesting
than
anything that i would do um moving
forwards and it's not
that i take the opportunity for granted
or that i wouldn't
you know i've learned that not acting
not working with actors again is stupid
so i would love to work with carrie [ __ ]
again and and i would love to work with
gene smart again
and tim blake nelson and justin thoreau
and kevin carroll and
you know and giovanna depot who i worked
with twice now
like these actors in the world of
watchmen but at the same time like
unless i have an idea that is as
important to me
as tulsa 21 was then i shouldn't do it
and i haven't had that idea
and i want to create the space versus
people are waiting for me to change my
mind
i want to create the space for people to
come forward and say i have an idea
and i i issue this invitation to anyone
out there
if you have an idea you know figure out
a way
to pitch it like but probably not to me
but like watchmen is not mine um
it's ours and uh i i
i want to see what what someone how
someone else interprets this
this incredible story my last question
for you
supposing this is the end of angela a
bar in this story
i'm curious if you feel like the show
ends on a hopeful note because we've
seen
hood of justice tried to get justice and
and failed
dr manhattan with all his powers um you
know her grandfather says he could have
done a lot more
um rooting out systemic racism is hard
uh as we saw on the show and dr
manhattan didn't solve poverty and he
didn't solve education
supposing that angela does inherit his
powers do you think this ends
on a hopeful note if you were a lawyer
and i were a lawyer i would i would i
would demand that you rephrase that
question because if i answer it then
it then it explicitly agrees with the
premise that she is a god
if i say it's hopeful so let's just say
we're going to stay in the ambiguous
space of not answering that
but what but what is clear is that she
is willing to become a god
because she why else would she eat an
egg
or step in the pool in the way that she
does so she's accepting the challenge
a challenge issued not from um
john ostermann or cal a bar or dr
manhattan whatever you want to call him
but actually a challenge that is issued
to her by her grandfather
the last thing that he says to her is
um he was a good talking about dr
manhattan he was a good he was a good
man but he could have done
more and so now
we get the sense that at least angela is
signing up for
um doing more uh so whether or not
it works out i think that that's
basically the call to action for all of
us right now
and not to not to pivot back into the
real world but i but that's what always
gives me optimism
that's you know that was the idea in
tomorrowland too which is like
the future is something that it's not
something that happens to you
it's something that you make happen so
it
by showing angela is willing to try to
do more
like that's the clarion call for
optimism and so
if we're basically saying uh i don't
think that this moment is gonna
go going to lead to a better future then
that's
the way what i'm hearing is so you
aren't willing to do anything about it
you know and that and so when you see
all these people in the streets
and lou was just talking about this the
other day i had you know the benefit of
being on a a panel with him
and he was wildly optimistic about the
moment that we're having
um right now and understandably
um uh yaya wasn't cynical but he was
concerned that
it was fleeting you know or like um
like what what's the perspective that i
should have in this moment from one of
our elders
you know who's basically seen the you
know the
the american century in an entirely
different context
and so like i i
i i would say that um
that this ending is just as hopeful as
the ending of the old testament the
original watchmen
which is there's a single character who
folds in his hands
the ability to expose this
plot of vites he's holding rorschach's
journal in his hands and he doesn't know
whether he should throw it in the cook
pile or whether it should be published
and his editor says to him i leave it
entirely in your hands
and so that's the idea is like up
it's it's it's just as much of as
hopeful as it is
in in the eye of the beholder if you see
it
as hopeful then it's an optimistic
ending
if you think that she's just gonna sink
to the bottom of the pool
and it was just like sort of an
elaborate um
uh prank that uh that that cal
played on her um uh then that
that holds true too it's a rorschach
test but
it's it's it's a comment more on the
person who's watching it or reading it
than it is
on on what actually happens next though
i think that you and i both know there's
going to be more watchmen
like i mean that's going to happen uh
and whether or not the individuals who
decide
that they want there to be more watchmen
pick this story up where it left off
or they or they do an entirely different
kind of watchman story
um that's that's up to them but i
i am seeing like a lot of people who
respond to the show
are catalyzed and interested in what the
world would look like if it were being
reshaped
by angela a bar um
and uh i don't have i don't have good
answers to that question but
that's that's why that's why it cut to
black when it did